احباط في حزب منقسم على نفسه بعد نتائج
مخيبه للامال حققها الجمهوريون في
انتخابات التجديد النصفي فلم تجري الامور
كما خطط لها كانت بدايه الاشارات السيئه
بخساره محمد اوز لمقعد مجلس الشيوخ في
بنسلفانيا هو المنصب الذي كان يشغله
جمهوري قررت تقاعد ليضيفه الديمقراطيون
اليهم ثم خسر الجمهوريون مقعد الشيوخ في
اريزونا وبعده مباشره خسروا مقعدا بعد ان
تغلبت ديمقراطيه كاثرين كورتيز ماستو على
الجمهوريه
لم تكن هذه النتيجه التي توقعها
الجمهوريون كانوا يريدون موزه حمراء
تمكنهم من تعطيل اداره للعاملين المقبله
فخرج الجمهوريون من نتائج او من انتخابات
مجلس الشيوخ وهم خاسرون ما دخلوا به يبقى
عملهم الان بان يفوز بجورجيا في انتخابات
الاعاده في السادس من ديسمبر يكون حجمه
اقلليتهم كما كان عليه قبل الانتخابات لكن
ذلك ليس امرا سهلا ايضا ايضا ايضا لم
ينتصر فهو في طريقه لخساره مجلس النواب ما
يعني انه سيطر لتقديم تنازلات للجمهوريين
من اجل تمرير اجنبته حتى انه اعترف
باقترابه من دخول حاله البطه العرجاء
السوار
يوتيوب يوتيوب
تاتي النتائج بينما ينوي الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب بان يقوم باعلان ضخم في
الخامس عشر من نوفمبر اي بعد يومين وكان
من شبه المؤكد ان يعلن بشكل رسمي ترشحه
لانتخابات 20 24 لكن الرياح السياسيه
معاكسه لطموح الرئيس السابق فقوه الدفع
التي اعتقد الجمهوريون انه سيمنحها لهم
تحولت الى قوه تدمير ذاتيه على ما يبدو
كانت رابط دعم في انتخابات مجلس الشيوخ
اعدم لك زعلت من نيفادا وبلايك ماسترز من
ارينا ومحمد من تنسلفانيا كلهم خسروا لم
ينجح ممن دعامهم ترامب الا جي دي فانز في
اوهايو ورانج جونسون في وسكانسن والاخير
سنه وله رصيده سياسي فلا يمكن نسبه فوزه
الى ترامب امارس في جورجيا فلم يتمكن من
الاطاحه بالمرشح الديمقراطي في الولايه
وذهب معه الى جوله اعاده مصيرها غيره ثم
صراعاته ترامب تسببت ايضا في شرخ في الحزب
الجمهوري لسراعه مع زعيم الحزب في مجلس
الشيوخ متش مكانل كانت ساحه هذا الشرخ
الاسكا حيث قدم الحزب مرشحتين لمنصب مجلس
الشيوخ واحده يدعمها ترامب والاخرى يدعمها
مكانل باموال الحزب ما حرم الجمهوريين من
فرصه تمويل ساحات اخرى حاسمه بدلا من
الاسكا مضمونه كل هذه النتائج تضع ترامب
في موقف صعب امام حزبه الذي يريد الحصول
على دعمه في انتخابات 20 24
يا حبيبي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ترامب لم يقتنع بالنتائج وقال عبر منصته
للتواصل الاجتماعي تروس سوشل ان الولايات
المتحده دوله فاشله وان الانتخابات في
نيفادا واريزونا بها تزوير يضيف ترامب ان
الديمقراطيين يختلقون اصواتا في نيفادا
واريزونا وان ما يحدث عار سياسي الرئيس
السابق قال ان الولايات المتحده دوله
فاشله من دول العالم الثالث حيث تم اجراء
انتخابات ملوثه ستسمح بفتح حدودها ياتي
ذلك بينما يواجه ترامب خساره المرشحه
لمنصب الحاكم في اريزونا وهي كاريك اقرب
حلفائه السياسيين في الوقت الحالي متابعه
ايضا في رصد هذه النتائج بينما يعاني
ترامب من هذه الانتكاسات يبدو انه يخسر
مكانته كذاعيما للحزب الجمهوري مع بروز
نجم الجديد
طويله
[تصفيق]
هو حاكم فلوريدا الذي فاز باكتساح في
انتخابات الولايه التي تعد متارجحه بين
الحزبين واستطاع انتزاع مناطق ديمقراطيه
في
فلوريدايد انتصار دي سانتوس الكاسح دفعت
رامب لجنه هجوم عليه وقال انه سياسي متوسط
المستوى ويمارس اللعيب غير نزيهه ياتي هذا
بينما الجمهوري خلف دي سانتوس مثلا صحيفه
نيويورك نشرت غلافا عليه صوره حاكم
فلوريدا وعنوانه دي فيوتشر بدلا من ذا
فيوتشر اي المستقبل نسبه الى ديسمبر كان
عنوان فوكس نيوز اقرب الى ذلك حيث وصفت
المحطه
بالقائد الجديد للحزب الجمهوريه كما انقلب
بعضه المتبرعين الجمهوريين على ترامب منهم
دونالدز وهو احد اكبر المتبرعين وسفير
امريكا في ج خلال اداره ترامب يقول ان
اعلان ترامب دعم بعض المرشحين اضر بفرسهم
ويؤكد ان الحسبه كان لديه اقوى حجج سياسيه
خلال 20 عاما لكن النتائج لم تعكس ذلك
يبقى سؤال اذا خرج ترامب يوم الثلاثاء
لاعلان ترشحه ما هي قوته السياسيه
الحقيقيه بعد نتائج هذه الانتخابات بعد كل
هذه الانتكاسات